las seis mil 847 juntas receptoras de
votos habilitadas para recibir el voto
de los costarricenses dentro y fuera del
país abrieron sin mayores contratiempos
la presidenta del tribunal supremo de
elecciones calificó de extraordinaria la
afluencia de los votantes que aseguró
atendieron los llamados a acudir
temprano a los centros de votación y
dijo que el flujo de votantes se mantuvo
hacia el mediodía la mayoría de los
principales aspirantes presidenciales
también acudieron a votar en horas de la
mañana los magistrados electorales
destacaron además que los votantes han
seguido las medidas sanitarias ordenadas
para el ejercicio del voto en medio de
la ola de la pandemia que vive el país
en esta elección unos siete mil
auxiliares kobe 19 se encargan de
supervisar el cumplimiento de las
medidas como lavado y desinfección de
manos y el distanciamiento físico
también está prohibida la instalación de
toldos de partidos afuera de los centros
para evitar aglomeraciones pero en
algunos puntos seguidores de distintos
partidos igual permanecieron en las
afueras de las instalaciones mil 689
candidatos compiten en esta elección
para ocupar 60 cargos el próximo
presidente sus dos vicepresidente y 57
diputados de la asamblea legislativa el
tribunal supremo de elecciones prevé un
conteo lento por la alta cantidad de
candidatos y partidos inscritos y por
las particularidades de la pandemia por
lo que el primer corte de resultados
será hasta las 20 45 o la local